unser zuschauer manfred rekurs aus
hamburg hat uns dazu ein zuschauer video
geschickt habe letztes jahr dezember
flüge über opodo sind ja nach fernost
gebot
leider wurde die krone kurze zeit später
von finnair diese flüge storniert
daraufhin habe ich versucht habe ich
eine e mail geschickt und habe um
rückerstattung eines fluges gebeten
diese e-mail wo wir nach knapp 42
monaten endlich beantwortet mit antwort
ich sollte ist der service center wäre
sich zuständig und ich sollte mich an
eine telefonnummer
senden dann kam die ansage diese annahme
telefonnummer ist leider nicht mehr
verfügbar
ein versuch mit einem einschreiben an
eine hamburger adresse wurde nicht
abgeholt und mir nach knapp drei wochen
wieder zurückgeschickt
ich sehe da keine möglichkeit mehr was
ich noch tun soll fällt da jetzt dass
sie mir helfen können ja wieder mal so
ein wahnsinns fall also eher schädlich
wirklich mit dem kopf aber es passiert
zu vielen zuschauern und dann müssen wir
das wirklich noch mal ganz genau klären
also tatsächlich habe ich einen flug
gebucht bei opodo wie sollte ich da
vorgehen wer ist denn überhaupt für mich
zuständig an wen wende ich mich von wem
bekomme ich mein geld zurück
bitte auch die reisebestätigung schauen
in den meisten fällen sind diese
internetportale sind nur vermittler dann
gibt es die verträge mit den
gesellschaften oder mit dem veranstalter
mit den fluggesellschaften übrigens auch
und wer das jetzt im einzelnen ist steht
auf der reisebestätigung und der ist
auch ansprechpartner
der ist nämlich meinen vertragspartner
es kann natürlich sein dass der die
fluggesellschaft sagt opodo wickelt das
für dich ab das ist aber im grunde
genommen muss eine interne abwicklung
interner abrede die mein ansprechpartner
bleibt immer der veranstalter den sollte
ich auch unter druck setzen und
schlimmstenfalls würde man hier eine
klage einreichen denn aus der
also aus der reisebestätigung bekommt
man ja die daten des anbieters den
vertragspartner und den verklagt man in
solchen fällen und wir haben in der fall
in der praxis die erfahrung gemacht dass
es dann ganz schnell geht weil die
gesellschaften dann nämlich nicht mehr
wegducken die können sich nicht mehr
wegducken die müssen sich ja bei
gerichten äußern ansonsten gibt es ein
versäumnisurteil und was wir hier auch
erlebt haben was ganz ärgerlich ist dass
die post zugestellt wird die einfach
nicht angenommen wird und da muss man
wirklich auch wissen und das bitte
unbedingt beachten
post die nicht abgeholt wird gilt nicht
als zugestellt das heißt ich kann wenn
ich jemanden einschreibebrief mit
rückschein schicken und er wird nicht
abgeholt der landet dann bei der post
dann ist das nicht zugestellt dann muss
ich das erneut machen weil ja durch die
rückgabe klar ist dass ihr das nicht
abgeholt hat es gibt zwar so etwas wie
eine zustell fiktion aber das nur ganz
besonderen fällen wir aber nicht deshalb
bitte immer per e mail per fax und
schlimmstenfalls per einwurf
einschreiben nie ein entwurf mit
rückschein weil dann muss der empfänger
etwas unterschreiben
ein einschreibebrief einwurf
einschreiben wird einfach nur zugestellt
und das gericht aus ja wirklich sehr
sehr wichtige tipps und tatsächlich
bekommen wir sehr viele beschwerden von
zuschauern
da fällt immer wieder der name opodo da
ist es auch wirklich kompliziert sind
die ansprechpartner oder doch die
airline tatsächlich der der rat von an
kims goldrichtig tatsächlich schauen sie
auf ihre rechnung schauen uns schauen
sie auf die buchungsbestätigung da steht
das dann
und tatsächlich mein appell wirklich ich
weiß aus eigener erfahrung ich mache es
auch nicht mehr wirklich nie bei online
reisebüros buchen die mögen vielleicht
ein paar cent günstiger sein und die
verben natürlich auch bei google mit
unglaublichen rabatten aber wenn man
dann vielleicht die falsche
zahlungsmöglichkeit auswählt dann wird
es dann doch wieder teuer also wenn sie
da ärger sparen war wirklich mein tipp
wie bei online reisebüros buchen